Everyone has their own idea of self care
for being honest.
Mine is just being at home in my kitchen
making something yummy.
It's the absolute coziest time of the year.
I love finding reasons to stay home
and snuggle my babies.
I'm partnering with Albertsons to
get grocery delivery today
so we can have a cozy winter dinner at home together
tonight! Tonight
I'm actually making a recipe I got from my grandmother
for chicken pot pie.
I use fresh veggies in it instead of frozen,
and I also use fresh rotisserie chicken.
It's the ultimate comfort food.
Albertsons makes it so easy
for me to make something for my family that is simple,
cozy, and comforting
all without even having to leave my house.